for the vaccine hunters there's no rest
this is where we designed the prototype
vaccine such as the urgency that
scientists at Imperial College London
had a prototype in a matter of weeks
they're one of two British teams in a
global race to prove their coronavirus
vaccine is safe and effective only
science works in the very safe and
steady way and do you feel the pressure
then to deliver definitely there's a
pressure to deliver we just recognized
like everybody else how much we need to
prevent fatalities and how much we need
to get the economy up and running again
it has affected everybody's life
tests are underway on volunteers their
antibodies and T cells made by their
immune systems analyzed back in the lab
results are closely guarded the vaccine
contains a snippet of the virus's
genetic blueprint it's a technique never
used before but it should be quick to
make 10 million doses a week but that's
nowhere near enough and the scientists
are well aware that countries such as
the United States could try to corner
the supply just as it did with the
treatment REM dezer veer luckily we're
not making our vaccine in the United
States so we sit outside of that it is a
deliberate policy it's something that we
were encouraged to do by the UK
government to make sure that there is
capacity in the UK for manufacturing and
you know we are looking to work with
partners which would also be able to
provide the vaccine without any of those
restrictions British vaccine trials have
been targeted by Russian state-sponsored
hackers according to the UK government
but it's not other nations stealing the
formula that scientists fear the most
what we're much more concerned about and
I think that the world will wake up to
very soon as as soon as one vaccine
works it will be the issue of fake
vaccines because if people can't access
the vaccine there will be people out
there he'll say oh I've got this vaccine
I managed to get a special deal come and
buy the vaccine from me and that is much
more of a concern that that people will
start to profiteer out of selling fake
vaccines to vulnerable populations
worldwide more than 20 prototype
vaccines are now in clinical trials with
130 or so following behind the US
company moderna has already shown its
vaccine triggers an immune response and
there are encouraging noises from Oxford
researchers that their results due next
week will also show that on track but
they're still a long way to go in the
race against the virus